why is it so difficult to make a great
movie there's just so many moving parts
to make a great movie I
mean and uh you look at films like
Apocalypse Now uh
Godfather um the the real the real great
movies um forest
scump and you there's so many moving
parts and so many people have to believe
in the
project um from the financiers to the
actors to the Distributors to the um
people that are making the adjustments
on the script and things of that
sort there is a there is a you know um
you really have
to uh get lucky frankly let's be real on
having all those things to come together
because it's not just the money it's not
just the money it's and it's not just
the big actor it's it's got to be the
whole thing I look at films like that
like Forest Gump and that's just a truly
brilliant piece um you know expansive
and meaningful it makes you cry it makes
you laugh um and it means something it's
it's and then you look at films
like uh Godfather series uh Apocalypse
Now all those truly great films um Taxi
Driver um
and I think
that it's just you got to get lucky in
so many ways and it's just timing and
you just do your best you're trying to
make a great film every time you're
trying to no matter how small you're
trying to do that's the beauty of it
right you're trying to everybody's
trying to make a great film The Greatest
film everyone does it come out to be the
greatest film but we're all trying and
some of them get there and some of them
don't so you know
you when you hit that lucky stride
of creativity and the right amount of
resources and money and the right amount
of right amount of talent behind
everything and then just the right
Synergy and energy then it turns into
you know something magic but it at the
end of the day it has to start with the
story and you have to have the story in
a way
that um you know people can get behind
it and give it the chance to be that
greatness so it's just got a lot of
different uh ways to skin that cat but
very few cats get skinned in that way so
so it's that's why they're so special
when we see them that's why we watch
them a thousand times that's why we uh
you know they get all the love and
adoration that they do well if we watch
um is it hearts of Darkness or Heart of
Darkness so we see that Copa did not
there was luck was not really on his
side for much of the film even though it
it it turned out incredible so he had
many things well I mean you know Harvey
kitel was the actor and they fired him
uh um Martin Sheen had a heart attack uh
they ran out of money several times
Marlon BR wasn't being cooperative I
mean it was it you know people it was it
was a it was a huge mess there were
government issues they right and they
and they have a whole if you see the
Redux it's the whole section of the film
wasn't even there
but there was a thread in that film that
is the same thread as on the
river that said that pulled the the boat
up the river to the and and that never
and there's a line there it says never
get off the boat and it's very
interesting because that ultimately is
about the story
never get off the boat there's too much
stuff going on the boat regardless of
all the chaos and they did a great job
of showing when they got off the boat
how much chaos there
was stay on the boat stay on the river
and then that lead you to the end chaos
but there's at least some kind
of closure
here so my feeling is that you
know a Heart Heart of Darkness I saw it
I was like a lot of people would have
given up a lot of people and he didn't
he stayed on the boat and got to the end
and and for that it's
brilliant and he also cooked it up in
the edit let's say you were going to
write a warrior filmmakers
Manifesto what would be some of the core
tenants you know
um I don't know I think I have some
written here but just you know sort of
like don't use a tool that you you don't
know much about or um uh don't become
overly attached to one particular
method yeah um that's okay well me
personally and it's been a theme
throughout the thing is that um don't
don't control everything let people do
their work
um don't try to be
uh you have to trust the
process and trust that everything is
going to turn out
okay and that trust is contagious
throughout the
set and when you have that you're set as
Allah lot of has
Harmony
second independent filmmakers you have
to cut out cancers and poisons quickly
you can't let them Fester inside of
production if you have people that are
being toxic if you have people that are
are disruptive you we must get them out
of there as soon as possible
because we don't have the time or money
to have we're in one war here we can't
have many wars within the war get rid of
it as soon as possible and get rid of
it so everybody understands that this
will not be tolerated it's very
important in indie film because films
can become a big mess
and
um you
know one of the things that's so
interesting that I've seen is
that a lot of films and I don't know if
I should mention that one film we talked
about but but I just looked at that
like that's like on every set it doesn't
matter $50,000 movie they all it's just
they have six seven million
do and they still have the same problems
as the $660,000 movie so it's not about
the money it's about the
management of of the of the project and
the team and and and when you have a lot
of really bad elements or or potentially
bad elements in that thing in in in your
film you have to get them out quick
don't let them Fester get it out of
there that's what that's the if you're
going to be a prod producer you got to
know that and you have to be able to
know where that's coming
from okay so that would be the manifesto
yeah I mean I I I have to think about a
Manifesto Warriors Manifesto I have to
think about like uh you know some of
those things that would um that would be
but I it uh you
know uh probably yeah just just keep
your your your set Harmony is everything
and that's how you get what you want you
have to keep keep you have to
concentrate on set Harmony if you if you
don't have set Harmony you're not going
to get what you want and you're probably
going to go over a budget and you're
probably going to not uh have the the
artistic outcomes that you're looking
for so keep your set calm and and
working well and let people do the work
that they're they're doing without being
too
heavy-handed and Trust the process just
to play The Devil's Advocate for a
moment
so I think if you are working with the
same crew then you know this person's
strong in this area and vice over here
this person's great at this but if it's
a new set coming together there would be
some problems so how can someone stop a
train wreck from happening when when
sometimes so many moving parts and egos
I don't know if it's possible that
people are going to have their own
agendas you know it's not possible and
it's one of the reasons that you should
strive as a filmmaker to find your crew
get a crew find even if it's they're
coming from everywhere but find that one
sound guy find the one art Department
people your film
Journey should
be you know a good portion of it not
just creation of a product but building
a team so that the creation of the
product becomes more efficient
so you can't you you can't you have to
just do the trial and error you're going
to find people and you just try to you
know get as good people as possible with
good and you know really do vetting if
you can but at the end of the day um
you're going to run into that and so you
just have to live and learn and learn to
keep things uh keep things moving and
get a really good line producer that's
strong and willing
to get rid of toxic elements poison
elements quickly so that they don't
Fester so you can keep moving forward
but at the end of the day you want to
get that's the whole point you know you
want to have your own crew you want to
you want to be able to have a team of
people you know that will let you know
you have a Shand with and and that you
don't have to worry about you don't have
to explain everything to them from
scratch if something happens they give
you the benefit of the doubt instead of
thinking that somehow you're coming from
a bad place so when you build that
that's what that 10 years is for or
whatever is to build up um a a team um
of people that uh you can trust and and
depend
on